the numbers are staggering since january
covet 19 has killed over 197
000 brazilians more people have died in
four months
than in all of last year but now the
pandemic
has taken a sharp political turn
congress is investigating whether
president jair bolsonaro
is responsible for the world's second
largest covet 19 death toll
after the united states bolsonaro is
accused of downplaying the dangers of
the virus
and the efficiency of the vaccines
last year the government rejected
several offers to buy the coronavec
and pfizer vaccines from china and
united states
delaying the mass inoculation campaign
this is the first time bolsonaro's
criminal actions are being investigated
the government not only denied the
pandemic but also confronted governors
and mayors who imposed restrictions to
protect the population
the supreme court barred the president
from overturning curfews and lockdowns
but now congress will hold him
accountable for his actions
bolsonaro's allies failed to stop
lawmakers from launching the probe
now a senate committee will be looking
into at least
20 accusations among them the
government's failure
to have a national plan senators say
that the priority is to investigate
why brazil took so long to procure
vaccines
despite being latin america's largest
economy and having the technological
means
to produce them domestically but
government officials
will also be asked about the delay in
resuming emergency aid
to the country's growing poor
19 million people have gone hungry
during the past year
almost twice as much as in 2018
and half of the population is facing
food insecurity
not knowing when they'll have their next
meal
many like this couple have moved to the
street
after the government suspended the
emergency aid in january
handouts started being distributed again
this month
but they still have not received them
nor have their new neighbors
this is mr goshu he had a shop and lost
everything during the pandemic
like him there are dozens sharing a
sidewalk
the pandemic and the economic crisis it
brought about are far from over
with less than seven percent of
brazilians fully vaccinated
it will be a long time before life goes
back to normal
meanwhile lawmakers are hoping the
investigation
will determine what went wrong and who
was to blame
monika yanakiv al-jazeera rio de janeiro